in the late 19th century scientists were
trying to solve a mystery and they found
that if they had a vacuum tube like this
one and apply the high voltage across it
something strange happened
they called them cathode rays but the
question was what were they made of in
England the 19th century physicist JJ
Thompson conducted experiments using
magnets and electricity like this and he
came to an incredible revelation these
Rays were made of negatively charged
particles around 2,000 times lighter
than the hydrogen atom the smallest
thing they knew so Thompson had
discovered the first subatomic particle
which we now call electrons now at the
time this seemed to be a completely
impractical discovery I mean Thompson
didn't think there were any applications
of electrons and around his lab in
Cambridge he used to lie to propose a
toast to the electron may it never be of
use to anybody he was strongly in favor
of doing research out of sheer curiosity
to arrive at a deeper understanding of
the world and what he found did cause a
revolution in science but it also caused
a second unexpected revolution in
technology and today I'd like to make a
case for curiosity-driven research
because without it none of the
technologies I'll talk about today would
have been possible now what Thompson
found here has actually changed our view
of reality I mean I think I'm standing
on a stage and you think you're sitting
in a seat but that's just the electrons
in your body pushing back against the
electrons in the seat opposing the force
of gravity you're not even really
touching the seat you're hovering ever
so slightly above it but in many ways
our modern society was actually built on
this discovery I mean these tubes were
the start of electronics and then for
many years most of us actually had one
of these if you remember in your living
room in cathode ray tube televisions but
I mean how impoverished would her lives
be of the only invention that I come
from here was the Tell
vision thankfully this chief was just
the start but if something else happens
when the electrons here hit the piece of
metal inside the tube let me show you
so as the electrons screech to a hole
inside the metal their energy gets
thrown out again in a form of
high-energy light which we call x-rays
and within 15 years of discovering the
electron these x-rays were being used to
make images inside the human body
helping soldiers lives being saved by
surgeons who could then find pieces of
bullets and shrapnel inside their bodies
but there's no way we could have come up
with that technology by asking
scientists to build better surgical
probes only research done out of sheer
curiosity with no application in mind
could have given us the discovery of the
electron and x-rays now this tube also
threw open the gates for our
understanding of the universe and the
field of particle physics because it's
also the first very simple particle
accelerator
now I'm an accelerator physicist so I
design particle accelerators and I try
and understand how beams behave and my
fields a bit unusual because it crosses
between curiosity driven research and
technology with real-world applications
but it's the combination of those two
things that gets me really excited about
what I do now over the last hundred
years they've been far too many examples
for me to list them all but I want to
share with you just a few in 1928 a
physicist named Paul Dirac found
something strange in his equations and
he predicted based purely on
mathematical insight that there ought to
be a second kind of matter the opposite
to normal matter that literally
annihilates when it comes in contact and
he matter I mean the idea sounded
ridiculous
but within four years they'd found it
and nowadays we use it every day in
hospitals in positron emission
tomography or PET scans use for
detecting disease or take these x-rays
if you can get these electrons up to a
higher energy so about a thousand times
higher than this tube the x-rays that
those produce can actually deliver
enough ionizing radiation to kill human
cells and if you can shape and direct
those x-rays where you want them to go
that allows us to do an incredible thing
to treat cancer without drugs or surgery
which we call radiotherapy and in
countries like Australia and the UK
around half of all cancer patients are
treated using radiotherapy and so
electron accelerators are actually
standard equipment in most hospitals or
a little closer to home if you have a
smartphone or a computer and this is
TEDx so you've got both with you right
now right
but inside those devices are chips that
are made by implanting single ions into
silicon in a process called ion
implantation and that uses a particle
accelerator
so without curiosity-driven research
though none of these things would exist
at all so over the years we we really
learnt to explore inside the atom and to
do that we had to learn to develop
particle accelerators and the first ones
we developed let us split the atom and
then we got to higher and higher
energies we created circular
accelerators that let us delve into the
nucleus and then create new new elements
even and at that point we were no longer
just exploring inside the atom we'd
actually learn how to control these
particles we'd learn how to interact
with our world on a scale that's too
small for humans to see or touch or even
sense that it's there and then we built
larger and larger
Raiders because we were curious about
their nature of the universe and as we
went deeper and deeper new particles
started popping up and eventually you
got to huge ring like machines that take
two beams of particles in opposite
directions
squeeze them down to lessen ur width of
a hair and smash them together and then
using Einstein's I equals MC squared you
can take all of that energy and convert
it into new matter new particles which
we rip from the very fabric of the
universe and nowadays there are about
35,000 accelerators in the world not
including televisions and inside each
one of these incredible machines there
are hundreds of billions of tiny
particles dancing and swirling and
systems that are more complex than the
formation of galaxies you guys I can't
even begin to explain how incredible it
is that we can do this
[Applause]
[Music]
so I want to encourage you to invest
your time and energy in people that do
curiosity driven research it was
Jonathan Swift who once said vision is
the art of seeing the invisible and over
a century ago JJ Thompson did just that
when he pulled back the veil on the
subatomic world and now we need to
invest in curiosity-driven research
because we have so many challenges that
we face and we need patience we need to
give scientists the time the space and
the means to continue their quest
because history tells us that if we can
remain curious and open-minded about the
outcomes of research the more
world-changing our discoveries will be
thank
[Applause]
[Music]